mais les forces de l'ordre très
sollicitée hier pour encadrer la journée
d'action des soignants il ya près de dix
jours christophe castaner avait annoncé
l'abandon prochain d'une techniques
d'interpellation controversées et des
mesures aussi pour lutter contre le
racisme chez les forces de l'ordre
eh bien ça ne passe toujours pas
plusieurs centaines de policiers se sont
rassemblés devant la préfecture de
police de paris
aujourd'hui ils s'estiment a injustement
accusé de racisme et de violence le
ministère de l'intérieur a tenté depuis
d'apaiser la situation de vie pour
certains à le mal est fait écouter ces
réactions la colère policière et là elle
est bien là et il va continuer le mal a
été fait c'est trop tard
lien de confiance qui auront peu que
miss d'intérieur ya une colère dans la
police déjà depuis des années plus de
deux ans sur le d'état de décrépitude de
notre institution
le manque de moyens de matériel le
ministre a mis le feu aux poudres avec
sa récente conférence de presse il ya
quelques jours lorsqu'il a parlé de
soupçons de racisme avéré il a
stigmatisé le corps de la police
nationale ce qui revient à dire que le
policier n'a plus de présomption
d'innocence c'est une présomption de
culpabilité
on a un ministre qui a cédé à une
pression de quelques communautariste
pour les stigmatiser sa police la
confiance était rompue avec le ministre
la confiance était rompue surtout avec
le gouvernement on voit bien que notre
ministre il a répondu à des consignes
qu'il n'est plus haut c'est pour ça que
nous alliance police nationale nous
avons demandé à être reçus le plus
rapidement possible chez le président de
la république parce qu'il ya des grands
thèmes qui n'ont pas été abordés
ni avec le ministre demie avec lui pour
le moment depuis le début du mandat
on a l'impression que la police est un
peu mise sur le côté
même si le président il a eu quelques
mots dimanche soir pour rappeler la
reconnaissance de la nation pour la
police c'est pas suffisant